وصفت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه جوله
المباحثات الاولى لترسيم الحدود بين لبنان
واسرائيل بانها مثمره وكان الطرفان قد
عقدا في بلده الناقوره جنوبي لبنان جوله
قصيره من المفاوضات التقنيه غير المباشره
برعايه امميه ووساطه امريكيه وقرر عقد
جوله ثانيه من المباحثات بعد
اسبوعين
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش في ما
وراءه ما هي المؤشرات التي يبعثها توقيت
انطلاق مباحثات ترسيم الحدود بين لبنان
واسرائيل والسياق الذي تتم في اطاره وما
فرص نجاح هذه المباحثات في ضوء تباين
تصوري جانبيها للحدود بينهما والتعقيدات
التي تكتنف العلاقه
بينهما
[موسيقى]
بجوله اولى قصيره استمرت نحو ساعه فقط
وبوسطه امريكيه وبرعاية
كان للعمليات في الجيش اللبناني العميد
بسام ياسين يرافقه ضابط اخر وخبير احدهما
في الطاقه والثاني في القانون الدولي شارك
فيها ايضا مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
ديفيد شنكر والمنسق الخاص للامم المتحده
في لبنان يان كوبيتش ووصفتها الامم
المتحده والخارجيه الامريكيه على التوالي
بانها كانت بناءه ومثمره وقد خلصت الجوله
الى اتفاق بعقد جوله ثانيه من المباحثات
في ال8 من الشهر
الجاري المفاوضات التقنيه غير المباشره
بين لبنان واسرائيل تتناول قضيه ترسيم
الحدود البحريه المتنازع عليها بين
البلدين حيث يقول لبنان ان مساحه المنطقه
المتنازع عليها تبلغ 850 ك مربعا داخل ما
تعتبرها اسرائيل منطقه اقتصاديه خالصه لها
بينما تقول تل ابيب ان مساحه المنطقه
المتنازع عليها 860 كت مربعا داخل المياه
اللبنانيه وقد تزامن انطلاق مفاوضات ترسيم
الحدود بين لبنان واسرائيل مع مناورات
عسكريه بالذخيره الحيه اطلقها الجيش
الاسرائيلي جنوب مدينه حيفا المناورات
التي تستغرق اسبوعا كاملا يحاكي خلالها بل
يحاكى خلالها لاع حرب مع حزب الله
اللبناني وتختبر جاهزيه الوحدات المختلفه
في خوض قتال شوارع واحتلال قرى في جنوب
لبنان وتاتي هذه المناورات في ذروه
الاستنفار الامني على الحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
في بدايه الحلقه من تل ابيب ايال عليمه
المراسل العسكري في اذاعه صوت اسرائيل قبل
ان يلتحق بنا ضيفان من بيروت وواشنطن ايال
عليمه ما هي الاهداف الاسرائيليه من وراء
الدخول والانخراط في هذه المفاوضات حول
الحدود مع
لبنان اولا الهدف المركزي والاكبر هو
اي تمكين اسرائيل من
استنفاذ المنطقه الاقتصاديه البحريه بمعنى
انها سوف تستطيع استخراج الغاز من هذه
المنطقه التي كانت منطقه متنازعه عليها
ولا تستطيع اسرائيل ان تستخدمها لاغراض
اقتصاديه خلال سنوات طويله من هذه الناحيه
التوصل الى هذا الاتفاق يمكن الطرفان
اسرائيل ولبنان من استخدام هذه المنطقه
لاغراض اقت اقتصاديه وهذا هو الهدف
المركزي وراء هذه الاتفاقات ونتذكر ان
كانت هناك طوال السنوات الاخيره بعض
المحاولات للتوصل الى اتفاق ما بين
اسرائيل ولبنان لترسيم الحدود في هذه
المنطقه التي تعتبر منطقه المياه
الاقتصاديه حيث لا توجد حدود متفق عليها
التوصل الى هذا الاتفاق يعود بالجدوى
للطرفين على ما يبد وبعد هذا الاتفاق هل
هناك سعي من خلال الاتفاق على الحدود بين
الطرفين هل هناك سعي اسرائيلي ربما لفتح
الباب الى ما هو ابعد من
ذلك هناك محاوله من قبل بعض الجهات
الاسرائيليه للحديث عن محادثات تاريخيه او
بانها بمعنى فتح صفحه جديده مع لبنان ولكن
ايه اذا نكون على ارض الواقع
اي الجانب الاسرائيلي يضك تماما بان هذه
المحادثات ربما وان تتجه في نهايه الامر
الى نتائج مثمره وان تؤدي الى اتفاق ما
بين اسرائيل ولبنان هذا لا يعني او لا
يغير الوضع القائم ما بين ال الطرفين
اسرائيل لا تزال في حاله حرب مع لبنان
وهذا الاتفاق لن يحل هذه الحاله لن يجعل
لبنان شريكا لاسرائيل لن
يجعله دوله صديقه لاسرائيل حاله الحرب
النزاع القائمه ما بين لبنان واسرائيل سوف
يستمر ما بعد التوصل الى الاتفاق بشان
ترسيم الحدود ونحن نعلم ان اسرائيل انسحبت
من لبنان عام 2000 وكان هناك ترسيم للحدود
رغم انه لم
يحص سي هناك من يتوقف اولا عند الضغوط
الامريكيه التي مورست على لبنان في هذا
الملف من اجل حمله على التفاوض وهناك ايضا
من توقف عند طبيعه وتشكيله الوفد
الاسرائيلي الى هذه المفاوضات بالمقارنه
مع تشكيله الوفد اللبناني وانطلاقا من كل
ذلك كان هناك تحليلات ذهبت الى القول بان
اسرائيل حقيقه تريد من وراء هذه المف
مفاوضات ان تفتح بابا اخر لا يقتصر فقط
على موضوع
الحدود ربما ولكن في نهايه
الامر الجانب الاسرائيلي يضك تماما على
الاقل الاجهزه الامنيه تدك تماما بان
الوضع ما بين اسرائيل ولبنان معقد اكثر من
كونه فقط ترسيم الحدود سواء كانت البحريه
او البريه منها هناك عوامل اخرى ايه ايه
لها تاثير في الساحه اللبنانيه هناك
العامل الايراني هناك حزب الله لا يتوقع
ان يحدث اي تغيير من هذه الناحيه لذلك لا
الاعتقاد الواقعي هو ان التوصل الى اتفاق
حول هذا الموضوع لن يؤدي الى تغيير حقيقي
فيما يتعلق بالاوضاع في الساحه اللبنانيه
وفي الجبهه الشماليه بش بشكل عام ا ايال
عليمه المراسل العسكري في اذاعه صوت
اسرائيل حدثنا من تل ابيب سنكتفي بهذا
القدر معك
وسنرحل من واشنطن الدكتور دانيل سروار
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جونز
هوبكنز وكبير الباحثين في معهد الشرق
الاوسط ونرحب كذلك بضيفنا من بيروت الكاتب
والمحلل والسياسي توفيق شومان مرحبا بكما
وسابدا معك سيد توفيق شو شومان يعني هناك
سؤال عن كيفيه توفيق لبنان بين الحديث عن
ان هذه المفاوضات تقنيه انه لا اعتراف
باسرائيل
وبين الذهاب الى مفاوضات حول الحدود مع
اسرائيل ستفضي بالنهايه الى اتفاق سيوقع
عليه الجانبين اللبناني والاسرائيلي اليس
هذا ضمنيا اعتراف وربما قد يذهب البعض الى
القول انه بدايه
تطبيع تحياتي اليك بدايه والى الزميل من
واشنطن وكل المشاهدين انا اعتقد انه لو
رجعنا يعني ولو بصوره عاجله وموجزه الى
تاريخ الصراعات والحروب منذ التاريخ
المكتوب ولغايه الان كل الدول وكل
المجتمعات والحروب وحتى القبائل قبل ان
نشهد بناء الدول كانت تتوصل في احيان
كثيره الى نوع من الاتفاقيات والمعاهدات
وال مفاوضات دون ان يلغي ذلك حاله الحرب
بينهما ربما اخر مثال على ذلك كان بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبين الاتحاد
السوفيتي بالرغم من ان الطرفين كانا
يتبادلان سفارات الى ان الحروب البارده
والساخنه كانت تغزو العالم الحروب
السوفيتيه والامريكيه طبعا اعود الى لبنان
انا اعتقد بانه لو فصلنا على الاقل بين
المفاوضات التقنيه وايضا المفاوضات
السياسيه مفترضه اظن بان هناك فارقا كبيرا
بينهما اي اتفاق سياسي بحاجه الى غطاء
حكومي وهذا غير متوافر ولا يمكن ان يتوافر
في الحاله اللبنانيه لذلك اظن ايضا لو
حاولنا ان نربط بين ما جرى اليوم وما قد
يجري ايضا بعد اسبوعين وربما يطول الامر
سنوات سنكون امام مفاوضات تقنيه بحته
شهدها لبنان على سبيل المثال في عده محطات
وفي محط وفي عده مفاصل من بين العام 2006
من بينها ايضا العام
196 من بينها ايضا العام هل يقارن ما يجري
اليوم بما جرى في عام 2000 و26 و96 لان
هذه تعتبر كما يقول البعض اول مفاوضات بين
الطرفين تجري على شان غير عسكري و بالوضع
الذي هو فيه لبنان اقتصاديا وسياسيا
والضغوط التي يتعرض لها هل بامكانك ان
تجزم
فعليا ان يبقى هذا الرفض الداخلي بشكل
كامل لاي خطوه مقبله
ربما مع اسرائيل قد يعني تفتح عليها هذه
المفاوضات الجاريه
الان لا في العام 2000 كان هناك سابقه
الخط الازرق او خط الانسحاب يعني وكان كان
واضح تماما كان الضباط اللبنانيون يفاوضون
على ذلك وانا اعرف اكثر من ضابط وف يعني
فاوض على ذلك ومع ذلك لم يؤدي الامر الى
اي عمليه تطبيع بين بين لبنان والكيان
الاسرائيلي انا اعتقد لا انه القراءه ربما
المستعجله التي فيها ابعاد سياسيه انا
اعتقد بانها قراءه فيها الكثير من الاتهام
دون ان يعني ذلك بانه عدم المفاوضات
التقنيه لا يعني بصوره او باخرى الجلوس مع
طرف عدو ولكن انه هذا الطرف العدو يتم
التحدث معه بصوره غير مباشره وبالتالي تحت
رعايه دوليه يعني الضباط اللبنانيون كما
عرفت بانه معهم تعليمات جازمه بمساله
اساسيتين الاول المساله الاولى عدم الخروج
نهائيا عن ما يرتبط وما يتعلق بالنقاط
التقنيه والثانيه ايضا عدم التحدث بصوره
مباشره مع الضباط الاسرائلي لكن هذا انت
تتحدث عن عن الان عن الان هذه المفاوضات
الجاريه الان ولكن ماذا لو مورث ضغوط على
لبنان في الاشهر المقبله في الاسابيع
المقبله ربما من اجل توسيع دائره هذا
الحديث وهذه المفاوضات هل باستطاعه لبنان
ان يقاوم هذه الضغوط بالوضع الاقتصادي
والسياسي الذي هو عليه
الان يعني طبعا هذا يندرج في عالم التكهن
سيدتي وفي عالم التنبؤ انه هذا امر قد
يحدث يعني قد تعمل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه على ربط تشكيل الحكومه
اللبنانيه
بالضغط بما يرتبط بالمفاوضات هذا امر هذا
امر محتمل ولكن انا اعتقد انا بانه مثل
هذا الامر انه قد يدفع الى نهايه
المفاوضات وبالتالي دفع لبنان نح نحو
الاضطراب لا ادري اذا كانت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بهذا الصدد ولكن حتى
يعني يعني طلعت على ما يمكن ان اعتبره
يعني كيف يحلل الامريكيون المرحله الاولى
من المفاوضات وما قبل وايضا كيف يحلل
الاسرائيليون هذا الامر لم اعثر على شيء
حتى من قبل الاسرائيليين لم اعثر على شيء
يعني على الاقل يحدد او يؤشر الى احتمال
ان ان تتحول هذه المفاوضات التقنيه الى
مفاوضات سياسيه لم ارى شيئا من هذا القبيل
يعني بيروت ترفض ذلك واشنطن عفوا واشنطن
ايضا لا تتحدث عن ذلك يعني على الاقل
لغايه الان ولا تلبيب ايضا تتحدث حدث عن
مثل هذا الامر طيب دعنا نسال ضيفنا
الدكتور دانييل سروار استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه جونز هوبكنز دكتور
دانييل ما سر الاهتمام الامريكي الكبير
بهذا الملف لدرجه ان تعمل على حله واشنطن
لسنوات اعتقد انه من الواضح انه بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ذلك سيكون شيء
عملي وسيمكن لبنان وبشكل خاص ان تستفيد
مواردها الطبيعيه في في هذا على هذه
الحدود البحريه وذلك سيكون مفيدا للبنان
ويقلل من الضغوط الواق على الولايات
المتحده وطبعا قد ايضا ياملون ان هذه
المحادثات الفنيه وفعلا انا اعتقد ان
حاليا ان هي فنيه صرفه ولكن نامل ان هذه
ان هذه
المحادثات التقنيه قد تؤدي الى تفاهمات
سياسيه جيدا علينا نتذكر ان شركات النفط
والغاز لن تستثمر في منطقه متنازع عليها
الا انك هناك اتفاق جيد والى ان الدول
تقوم الدول معنيه
بقبول التعيش بسلام مع بعضها الاخر مما
يعني الاعتراف المتبادل فلو ارادت لبنان
ان تطور وتستفيد من
مواردها فان على لاد ان تتجه الى اتجاه
سياسي في ذلك ايضا لكن كيف نفهم دكتور
دانيل يعني انت تقول لي ان الولايات
المتحده تريد للبنان ان يستثمر هذه الثروه
الطبيعيه لديه من اجل ان يحسن وضعه
اقتصاديا وبالتوازي واشنطن تمارس عليه
ضغوط اقتصاديه كبيره يعني تساهم في تدهور
وضعي الاقتصادي كيف نفهم هذا
الامر
اعتقد ان طريقه فهم هذا الامر هو ان
واشنطن هي صديقه للبنان وليست صديقه لحزب
الله وان
العقوبات تهدف الى اضعاف حزب الله لا اعرف
ان كانت تحقق ذلك النتيجه ام لا هذا امر
مختلف ولكن ما ما تريده واشنطن ان تكون
صديقا للبنان وللبنانيين وان تكون عدوا
لحزب الله
و الايرانيين ام توفيق شومان برزت خلافات
داخليه لبنانيه على تشكيله الوفد
اللبناني برايك كيف ستتطور هذه هذه
الخلافات حول تشكيله الوفد اللبناني وكيف
ستنعكس
على
المفاوضات يعني طبعا اليوم شارك الاربع
يعني اربع شخصيات اثنين ضباط لبنانيين
واثنين ايضا خبراء في في المفاوضات التي
جرت اليوم او المفاوضات الافتتاحيه ولكن
يعني بحسب المعلومات على الاقل التي
نمتلكها الان وربما هذه قد تتغير بين لحظه
واخرى بانه في الجوله الثانيه قد يتم خفض
عدد اعضاء المفاوض اللبناني وبالتالي
اقتصاره على العسكريين فقط يعني العميد
والعقيد واسماؤه معروفه امس كما اصبح
معروفا يعني اصدرت قياد لكن هذا امر لم
يعلن بعد وبالتالي لا يمكن ان نتعامل معه
سيد توفيق شومان ما نتعامل معه حاليا هو
ان هناك بيان صدر عن الثنائي الشيعي حزب
الله وامل يرفض التشكيله التي كان عليها
هذا الوفد ومع ذلك ذهب الوفد بالشكل الذي
شكل عليه ذهب الى المفاوضات وتمت
المفاوضات وايضا جرى تعيين جلسه اخرى جلسه
مقبله لهذه المفاوضات بالتالي كيف نفهم
هذا الرفض على الاقل حتى الساعه المعلن من
حزب الله وامل هل هو رفض شكلي ام انه
سيكون له تابعات
باعتقادك لا بدون شك ليس هو رفض مضموني
وليس رفضا شكليا ويعني اتحدث معك وامام
المشاهدين وفق لما املكه من معطيات انه
كان هناك اتصالات جرت على ما على ما اي
بين يعني بين بين الثنائي وبين رئاسه
الجمهوريه لم يتم الاتفاق على ضروره خفض
الوفد اللبناني بعد ذلك جاء البيان الذي
اصبح معروفا وتم تداوله في وسائل الاعلام
كافه ولكن ايضا المرحله الثانيه انا اعتقد
او المرحله الثانيه من المفاوضات اظن او
اكد اجزم يعني بان الوفد اللبناني يمكن ان
يخفض وبالتالي لا قصار الامر فقط على على
الجنرالين وهذا ايضا له سابقه كما ذكرت
قبل قليل يعني كان الضباط اللبنانيون هم
الذين فاوضوا الاسرائيليين عبر طرف ثالث
بعد الانسحاب الاسرائيلي من معظم الاراضي
اللبنانيه في العام 2000 وما نتج عنه
انذاك وما عرف بخط الانسحاب اي الخط
الازرق انا اعتقد بانه هذا الامر ايضا
يمكن ان يتفهمه القصر الجمهوري خصوصا بانه
اذا كان الثنائي لديه اعتراض ايضا لدينا
ايضا رئاسه الحكومه المستقيله ايضا كان
لديها اعتراض عندما اعتبرت بانه بان رئيس
الجمهوريه كان يجب ان ينسق ايضا يعني نحن
حقيقه امام هذا الموضوع انتقادك
موضوع اعتراض رئاسه
الحكومه يعني اصدرت كما تعرفين اصدرت يعني
رئاسه الجمهوريه اليوم بيانا توضيحيا حول
هذا الامر واعتبرت بان المساله ما زالت
مرتبطه في المراحل الاولى وبالتالي بانه
هذه المفاوضات لن تؤدي الى عقد معاهده
دوليه بحسب الماده 52 من الدستور اللبناني
بانه رئيس الجمهوريه هو الذي يتولى
المفاوضات بما يتعلق بالمعاهده الدوليه
وبعد ذلك يتم ابرام مع وابرامها بالاتفاق
مع رئاسه الحكومه اللبنانيه الان رئاسه
الجمهوريه اعتقد بانه تعتبر بانه هذه
المفاوضات لن تؤدي الى عقد معاهده دوليه
وبالتالي ربما لا حاجه الى التنسيق مع
رئاسه الحكومه اللبنانيه طيب دانييل سروار
هناك من يعني لاحظ او ربط بين انطلاق هذه
المفاوضات بين لبنان واسرائيل بعد ان عملت
الولايات المتحده على مدى سنوات من اجل
التقريب والدفع باتجاه هذا الامر
وبين التطبيع الجاري في المنطقه بين بعض
البلدان الخليجيه واسرائيل ما رايك بهذا
الربط
اعتقد ان
امريكا توود ان تحقق اكبر قدر ممكن من
التطبيع بين الدول العربيه
واسرائيل ولن
يكونوا بؤساء لو ان هذه المفاوضات البحريه
التي هي لحد الان مجرد مفاوضات تقنيه ان ه
المفاوضات تطورت
لتصبح ال
سكني لا اعتق انهم
يتوقعون ذلك بشكل كبير ذلك هناك سجل طويل
من العداءات الصعبه بين لبنان واسرائيل
وليس هناك اي سجل او ماضي
لوجود اي خلافات تاريخيه ب بين اسرائيل
والامارات العربيه والبحرين وبالتالي
يعتقد ان التطبيع
وانهاء العداء
واعتراف المتدد د لحد الان بعيده الامكان
حتى لو توصلوا مع لبنان الى اتفاق تقني
وذلك دانيل دكتور دانيل الا ترى ان
الولايات المتحده بهذا الاهتمام الكبير
والرعايه الكبيره التي توليها لهذه
المفاوضات الا تعتقد
انها يعني ربما تعول على هذه المفاوضات
بان تفتح بابا بين الطرفين لما هو ابعد من
فقط الاتفاق على الحدود ربما ليس الان
ربما بعد
فتره اعتقد انهم يفعلون ويملون ذلك بان
الامر سيؤدي الى ذلك ولكن على رجح ليس في
الوقت الحالي ما ينبغي ان نعرفه هو ان
لبنان تدخل هذه المفاوضات وهي في حاله
ضعيفه فهي ضعيفه اقتصاديا وضعيفه سياسيا
وتحتاج لبنان ان تستطيع ان
تستطيع استفاده من
مواردها الطاقه وما موجود في هذه المياه
وهو ما لم تفعله منذ سنوات بحيث كان يمكن
الاستفاده منها عليهم ان يفعلوا ذلك الان
وبالتالي اعتقد ان هناك احتمال لاتفاق فني
قد يؤدي الى اتفاق سياسي او لا لا نعرف لا
احد يعرف ذلك امريكا سترحب بذلك اذا ما
حصل هل يرتبط هذا المسار باعتقادك
ب الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه انه مسار
مستمر بغض النظر عن من يشغل البيت
الابيض ان هذا الالتزام لمساعده في هذه
المفاوضات بالذات سه الالتزام
سيستمر بصرف النظر عن من هو
راس الرئيس او من هي الاداره اللي تحكم
واشنطن اعتقد ان هذا الدور الامريكي في
المفاوضات سيستمر بين لبنان
واسرائيل و هذا ليس موضوع يتعلق بال
الحزبين في
تفيق توفيق شومان اذا استمعت الى ما قاله
ضيفنا من واشنطن لبنان ضعيف الان سياسيا
واقتصاديا وبالتالي في هذه الحاله او هذه
الحاله كيف ستنعكس على وضعه
التفاوضي يعني طبعا هذا ليس في صالح لبنان
واضح تماما اتفق معه تماما يعني زميل من
واشنطن بانه الوضع الداخلي اللبناني متازم
على المستوى السياس ليس فقط على المستوى
الاقتصادي بل انه على المستوى السياسي
وربما هذه قد تكون احدى اضعف الاوراق
اللبنانيه لذلك اظن بانه من الضروري بمكان
ان تلتئم القوى اللبنانيه وبالتالي تجتمع
على قرار واحد وبالتالي على مسار واحد
بصرف النظر ايضا مره اخرى عم من يمكن ان
يدير الاداره الامريكيه الديمقراطيون ام
الجمهوريون ولكن بصوره اساسيه اعتقد بانه
الخلافات السياسيه في لبنان واستمرارها
زائد انه الحالات الانهياريه على المستوى
المالي وعلى المستوى الاقتصادي هذا تضعف
اوراق المفاوض اللبناني هلا كيف يمكن ان
تلتئم الامور وبالتالي ان يذهب اللبنانيون
نحو كلمه سواء انا اعتقد بانه هذا بحاجه
الى عقل الرحمن يعني يمكن ان ينزل على
عقول السياسيين اللبنانيين ولكن بصوره
عامه ربما ايضا الجوله الاولى من
المفاوضات قد تؤهل اللبنانيين اذا كانوا
فعلا يريدون الوصول الى نهايات سعيده والى
خواتيم سعيده ايضا ان يتم توحيد المواقف
ضمن ورقه تفاوضيه واحده ضمن فريق سياسي
واحد يساند المفاوض المفاوضين العسكريين
من الخلف وبالتالي ان يكون هناك قرار واحد
موقف واحد وقياده سياسيه واحده تقف خلف
المفا خلف المفاوض العسكري اللبناني شكرا
جزيلا لك اي من بيروت الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي توفيق شومان وشكرا لضيفنا من
واشنطن الدكتور دانييل سروار استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جونز هوبكنز
وكبير الباحثين في معهد الشرق الاوسط
نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده في ما
وراء خبر جديد شكرا لمتابعتكم الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ه